now to the latest from the war in
Ukraine where president zielinski is out
with a new warning about what Russia
might do now both sides are preparing
for a likely battle for control of a key
Province and Russia's continuing
airstrikes on Ukrainian cities this
morning Russian TV showed President
Vladimir Putin visiting recent drafty
soldiers who are training to fight Holly
Williams is in Ukraine's Capital that's
Kiev where president zielinski claims
Russia is plotting a large-scale
disaster in his country Holly yikes that
sounds very ominous what do you think
this is all about
yes good morning while President
zielinski claims that Russia is planning
to blow up a dam in southern Ukraine and
has already laid mines he says it would
impact hundreds of thousands of people
and could even leave a nuclear power
plant without water for cooling
Russian State tv showed Vladimir Putin
visiting a training base for mobilized
troops trying out a new sniper rifle for
himself and admiring the boots his
soldiers wear on Ukraine's deadly front
line do you think he's logical right now
uh my personal opinion he's unhealthy
Vitale Klitschko is the mayor of Kiev a
former World Heavyweight Champion and a
symbol of Ukraine's resistance he told
us his country urgently needs better air
defense systems you've been asking the
West for more air defense systems since
February you must be frustrated
um I don't want to complain I just tell
please
please
we need that he's begging for help
because of this
a new wave of Russian strikes that
Ukraine says destroyed 30 percent of its
power stations in just over a week the
government's warning of rolling
blackouts
they want to make our citizens freezing
in the winter Natalia shkarupa and her
daughter elorna live in a tiny apartment
in the suburbs of Kiev if the heating
doesn't work this winter Natalia told us
they'll go and stay in her parents house
where there's a wood burner
giving up is not an option she said we
believe there's a bright future what did
you learn from boxing
that has been useful to you during this
war it's not important you size much
more important will to win and spirit
the U.S says it has information that
troops from Iran are on the ground
supporting Russian drone attacks here in
Ukraine the Ukrainian government claims
that Russia's ordered nearly two and a
half thousand so-called Kamikaze drones
from Iran Tony
I will be watching out for Holly
Williams and Ukraine for us Holly thank
you very much